the waste is astonishing if it were any
other Department the Department of
Defense would be on the front cover of
conservative magazine week-in week-out
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with Charles CW cook
who works at National Review and as the
author of the new book the conservatory
and manifesto libertarians conservatives
and the fight for the rights future
Charles thanks for talking to us thanks
for having me what is a conservatory in'
and why do we need them so I'm sure I'm
gonna get letters about this this is my
take on what conservatory anism is and
should be I didn't come up with this
word I've seen this around people have
introduced himself by saying they're a
conservatory Anor a liver Servet 'iv
yeah they say well I know thank you for
not going with liberal right I think
conservator and it's more euphonious
yeah but you know these are the people
who say when they're around libertarians
they feel conservative when they're
around conservatives they feel
libertarian and from what I can see the
fault lines are that they disagree with
libertarians on immigration foreign
policy and sometimes abortion and they
disagree with traditional conservatives
on federalism on gay marriage and on
drugs and they tend to be disappointed
with the Bush years not just because of
Iraq sometimes not because of Iraq but
because of No Child Left Behind if
Medicare expansion of the spending and
of a general feeling that Republicans
don't live up to their rhetoric so it's
a manifesto what is your what's your
what are you manifesting for what's the
solution that you're after
so the manifesto part is a little bit of
a joke as is the read cover this is not
a book with a hundred policy
prescriptions and there's a reason for
that the heart of the book is federalism
the heart of the book is trying to work
out a framework within which the right
can coexist and the country can coexist
we do live in a country that's deeply
divided it's a cliche but it's true
indeed we live in a country in which
many people have nothing in common with
one another at all you think about a
hipster in Brooklyn or in Portland
Oregon then you think about a Baptist in
Mississippi they have a common language
and that may be it you might be pushing
it well right
how does federalism allow
people two very different people to
co-exist well I think if you look at the
moment a key issue is drugs so you have
people in Colorado and people in
Washington they've got together they've
decided to legalize marijuana now
personally I think that's a good thing I
don't think that it should be pushed on
people who don't want it for their
communities or for their states but if I
had been in Colorado or Washington I
would have voted for it and along comes
Washington DC and says that's not legal
according to us for the first time
you've got some pushback against federal
rules that are at the best I'm clear and
at the worst oppressive certainly in
theory the federal government has the
right to come down on Colorado and
Washington that the racial decision made
that clear so I see nothing wrong with a
country in which Mississippi Idaho says
no to marijuana and Colorado and
Washington say yes that we don't have to
elect a president on this question we
don't have to say well I'm voting for
Elizabeth Warren because she's in favor
of weed I'm voting against Jeb Bush
because he's against it what are the
limits of that or sketch out quickly
because would you say the same thing
about liquor would it be okay if this
state said you know we're gonna be a dry
state as opposed to doing it at the
county or local level or we're gonna
have abortion here we're gonna ban it
fully how do you draw the line between
an issue that should be settled at the
national level or the federal level
versus at the state or local level right
well the two examples that you mentioned
I think constitutionally yes a state can
ban liquor and a Kanban or I don't think
the Roe vs. Wade decision is correct I
think it should be able to make its own
decision on abortion clearly there are
some questions that have to be dealt
with nationally they are natural
monopolies if you will immigration is
one of them you you can't have open
borders in California but not in the
other 49 states you'd have open borders
similarly I don't think foreign policy
can be conducted by the states and so
you need a national policy here but most
questions can be gay marriage can be
abortion can be the drinking age and
when whether one drinks at all can be
taxes building codes education how but I
mean at what level does a right and how
do you decide of where a right is is the
right of Anna Mae
because you wouldn't say racial
segregation should be decided at the
state level so why should gender
segregation or sexual orientation
segregation - what my marriage I think
this comes down to what you believe the
Constitution says not what you think it
should say I'm in favor of gay marriage
but what it actually says and so as far
as I'm concerned that the Bill of Rights
the Fourteenth Amendment they're clear
now I'm very clear in the book civil
rights has to be enforce federally not
only is there a constitutional
justification for that but I think
American history shows it's good policy
what what percentage of conservatives
would you say are in favor of gay
marriage and pot legalization well this
is a generational split and it's
something that the party is gonna have a
problem with increasingly Young
Republicans young conservatives are in
favor of gay marriage I think there's a
majority and depending on who you ask
there is almost a majority for marijuana
legalization or there is a majority the
outlier is abortion people always talk
about these three issues as if they're
the same thing they're not they're very
separate questions now and in fact
younger younger Americans cross the
border more conservative honorable or
more anti-abortion than older
generations which they're not on the
other issues that's absolutely right
yeah when you're talking libertarian ish
lis I find a lot to agree and I think
you're both fantastic so let's talk
about immigration and a national defense
one of the things that I think a lot of
libertarians are certainly I do find it
bizarre about kind of conservative
approaches to immigration is that
somehow the government that they're
conservatives are constantly and rightly
harping on as being inefficient and
stupid and incapable of tying its own
shoes much less delivering the mail or
providing education or anything like
that they're going to be able to both
secure the borders in a way that does
not infringe on people's civil liberties
but they're also then when they start
talking about well we're just going to
let in people who can work well and this
and that somehow they're going to be
able to adjust the demographic
population of 300 million plus people to
meet all of our needs in terms of ethnic
diversity as well as you know what jobs
people can do how do you you know
how can any conservative really think
the government is gonna be good at that
well I think that's an excellent
critique and I'm not sure I would say
government's always going to be good at
it what I would say and I think Milton
Friedman made this point as well is that
we already have a government that is so
deeply woven into the economy and into
our lives that to just allow people to
come in and if you look at the polling
on this I mean tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions of people would
want to would be to put some pressure on
our existing welfare system would that
be such a bad thing if it wouldn't that
also forced reform of the welfare system
it's possible it would force reform I'm
not so convinced we're trying to
maximize the contradictions well I'm not
I'm not convinced by that in that you
hear people say well let's go back to
how we were 100 years ago sink or swim
that's why immigration worked I don't
have so much of a problem with that but
I don't think the modern American public
is willing to watch people sink or swim
once they're here is there any data that
would help allay your concerns if we
open the borders more so because one
things that conservatives say a lot of
the times is I hate people who jump the
line or don't stand in the queue there
really is no line or queue for people
unless you are related to somebody who's
here or you are generally speaking a
high skilled worker who has a job offer
from a company there last year there
were about a million legal immigrants to
the country there were fewer than that
illegals and that waxes and wanes
depending on job opportunity but if you
knew for a fact that immigrants were
kept from getting most welfare benefits
if they committed crimes at lower levels
if they actually did come here to work
and that was basically what they did
would that allow your concerns about
opening up the country to more
immigration it would allay some of those
fears I do think and this is perhaps
where a conservative like me on this
disagrees with a libertarian like you I
do think the existing polity gets to
decide who joins them and I do think
they get to set the criteria by which
those new arrivals are are permitted to
enter the country now I'm under no
illusions that that's going to work
perfectly all the time of course it's
not as you say government is like
people with strange accents they do
myself ended oh really I thought that
was the speech impediment I'm sorry no
I'm just putting it on to sell votes do
you worry about the cultural
assimilation argument that a lot of
conservatives seem to be very upset
about when you know and I hear a lot of
people they say you know what I can't
stand is when I'm walking through a
street in an American city and I hear a
foreign language do you worry about that
I don't worry about the language so much
no because if you look at if you look at
the adoption of English how long it
takes for immigrants to adopt English it
does seem to be a lot shorter now than
it was 100 years ago that's not what
worries me so much what worries me is
that a hundred years ago you couldn't
burden your fellow or new fellow
countrymen as quickly as you can now you
couldn't vote to change the government
you couldn't vote for a big government
party that would ride roughshod over the
Constitution you couldn't raise taxes by
demanding more more benefits and so
forth now I agree with you that it would
change the equation slightly if it could
be guaranteed that newcomers would not
use welfare benefits but statistically
they do the data that I've seen you know
if you count public education for kids
through K through 12 often times who are
born here and then are American citizens
and some Hospital
you know admissions but they are
actually banned for most most other
forms of welfare so I mean they'll take
so you know they may get some food
stamps they may get some you know eight
to families with dependent children type
of programs but it's pretty minimal
I think this probably is going to depend
on how we define it but you know if you
if you look at the long-term use of
welfare by those who entered the country
as immigrants and their children it has
added a considerable amount to to the
rolls over that since 1965 that that's a
conscious decision that we made now I
accept their arguments on both sides I
accept some economists would say well
yes but they also contribute to the tax
rules they also fill those jobs they're
also entrepreneurs and so on and so
forth but again I think that decision is
for the polity to make if you open the
borders you take it out of their hands
and you and you allow those people to
change the country and I think countries
are fragile they're more than just
economies let's talk about
national defense you recognize in the
book that Iraq and Afghanistan were
basically disasters these you know these
did not go the way the architects of
them wanted at all do other
conservatives agree with you on that
because I don't see a lot of kind of you
know thinking through the next
intervention and we're already seeing a
lot of very high-profile conservatives
people at the National Review people at
the Weekly Standard calling about okay
now we've got to really start bombing
Iran or something close to it people
like Tom cotton in the Republican Party
there's a lot of real fire brands out
there is it just is it really just out
of the presidential candidates even is
it just Rand Paul the only one who's
saying and even he it from a libertarian
perspective is I wouldn't quite say he's
a war monger but he's not he's no
shrinking violet it is but are there
conservatives who actually agree Iraq
and Afghanistan were disastrous and we
need to be slow before we embroil
ourselves in the third act of these two
disasters
there are some but I don't think they're
enough and I make the point in the book
that Barack Obama came in on the back of
a certain anti-iraq sentiment and it
wasn't contrary to the American
character the American character Flitz
to and fro on the question of its role
in the world the anti interventionist
sentiment has been there from the
founding and it bubbles up occasionally
it bubbled up after the first world war
bubbled up after Vietnam it's bubbled up
after Iraq we are now seeing a little
bit of a return
now how many conservatives take my
position which is that the United States
needs to be strong it needs to be the
strongest nation in the world and to
retain its position there but that Iraq
was a mistake that one doesn't have to
lead to the other I don't know in order
to be the strongest country in the world
do we have to increase the fence
spending from what it's at now do we
have to every once in a while drop some
bombs somewhere to make you know to keep
it fresh in their mind that we mean
business because I think a lot of
libertarians and if we're talking about
trying to forge a
an alliance between the two you know
they're not against defense spending and
they're not necessarily sore constantly
increasing and they're in favor of
national defense yeah well look i should
say full disclosure on this one this is
not one of the areas and I make this
clear in the book on which I think
conservatives and libertarians can
compromise or coexist I come out and say
I think conservatives are closer to the
truth on on this to those questions I
don't think we need to drop bombs to
remind people were in charge although if
you are going to be the indispensable
nation you are sometimes going to have
to get involved you know I mean I think
we would probably agree on the basics
that we needed to fight the Japanese and
we needed to fight Nazi Germany and then
we disagree on some of the other smaller
questions on the question of defense
spending
I think conservatives really damaged
themselves here it does not need to
increase permanently every year secondly
the waste is astonishing if there were
any other Department the Department of
Defense would be on the front cover of
conservative magazines week in week out
recently it was it was revealed that
they can't even audit themselves they
don't even know where the money is going
and this is a huge problem that being
said I think in 1945 the British Empire
began to collapse the baton was handed
to the United States it finds itself in
the position of power and it cannot
relinquish that without permitting
another nation to come in and take that
role and I do not want to see it does it
matter that America is not an empire or
I'd never sought to be an empire and you
know as part of the reason that the
British Empire collapsed is precisely
because it was not a republic anymore
but it turned into an empire and spent a
lot of time maintaining colonies through
military force and military presence all
around the world rather than becoming a
better and better traitor and a stronger
and stronger beacon internally of the
values that it sought to project
throughout the world I don't think
they're quite comparable I think the
British Empire was there in various
forms for 250 300 years and even in that
18th century you had Macaulay saying
that the greatest day would be when the
Imperial possessions could be given up
America's never wanted that role maybe a
brief flirtation with it in the early
20th century it got that role because
it's closest historical and and I
logical partner collapsed in exhaustion
after the Second World War
now I understand people find that
frustrating the the instinct the
American instincts since the founding
has been to throw up one's hand and say
no we don't want to be in this position
but it is in this position and I think
reluctantly one just has to accept that
talk a bit about entitlements middle
class entitlements old-age entitlements
a lot of conservatives including some of
your colleagues a National Review will
say things like oh well you know of
course conservatives want to they want
to solve Social Security's problems but
they also are like this is a middle
class entitlement and we shouldn't
really be getting rid of it it seems
like a lot of libertarians are more of
the mindset that these are unsustainable
transfers of wealth from relatively
young relatively poor people to
relatively rich relatively old and
politically connected people is the
entitlement question how you know how do
conservatives and libertarians line up
in your view of things so I'm more
radical on this and a lot of
conservative conservators badly why and
what conservatives we are seeing an
intergenerational wealth transfer at the
moment that was not what was intended by
Medicare or Social Security more
importantly we know that it's
unsustainable and we're choosing it
anyway and I think that's the
unforgivable part of this you read
Middlemarch by George Eliot this is odd
comparison but bear with me
Rosenman starts to spend money that she
and her husband don't have not because
he needs it to tide him over bad times
or because he thinks that it will help
him invest in his future but because she
wants stuff she thinks it's the better
way to live America's got itself into a
position with entitlement spending in
which the people have been convinced
that although they can't afford these
entitlement spending it would be immoral
to get rid of them or at least to reform
them or restructure them I think that's
immoral in and of itself I also think
and I understand this is a radical
suggestion but I also think many of
those entitlements can be pushed back to
the states I see or at least privatized
so no I'm not
prevent argument see what libertarians
are often accused really of having an
unfair appeal to young people because
you know we'll talk about drugs we'll
talk about sex we'll talk about rock and
roll we su tradition often have a
contrarian or an anti-authoritarian
point of view what is the appeal of
conservativism to a younger generation
and it does seem as if when you look at
polling including polling that reason
did last year of Millennials there's
there's a sour taste for most
Millennials towards conservatives well I
do think you're right I think that split
on drugs and sex is probably important
conservatism is successful when the
alternatives have failed or a deemed to
be unviable and now my view is that in
the upcoming years libertarians and
conservatives will have to work together
in order to take power they're not happy
bedfellows often but they are probably
going to be happier than they would be
if they were with progressives I don't
think that means that young people are
suddenly going to love conservatives
indeed I'm not sure that means that
anyone's going to suddenly love
conservatives but if there is enough of
a coalition if there is enough of a
enough comity between the two movement
then you may be able to combine some of
the libertarian appeal I think gay
marriage and marijuana is appealing to
young people as I said and the the facts
of life part of conservatism that after
Barack Obama and his experiment and
probably given the entitlements crisis
that we're facing is going to look more
attractive what what binds conservatives
and libertarians together more than a
kind of historical or sociological
accident and it's interesting talking to
somebody is writing a National Review
which really created the modern right
which was founded by conservatives and
some libertarians I mean there was the
whole concept of fusion ISM that
anti-communism particularly was a strong
enough overarching goal that
conservatives and libertarians could get
along that was always a fraught alliance
as certainly after the Cold War it
started falling apart as I think people
in at least in America in a post-war
setting classical liberals of a
libertarian variety versus conservatives
you know realized there were a lot of
references so other than the kind of
historical accident that the people who
founded National Review the people who
created a kind of right that consisted
you know brought to light people like
Barry Goldwater and Donald Reagan who
enjoyed broad support among
conservatives and libertarians is there
a glue there other than a rejection of
progressivism or is that actually the
main kind of coming together point well
III think that they are
I think philosophically they start from
the same point even if they don't end up
in the same place you know libertarians
and conservatives mistrust the the
centralizer who tells you he knows
everything they don't believe that human
nature changes they are mistrustful of
power and I try to make this point in
the book that conservative is really the
wrong word sometimes conservatives can
go on to an accident of history and just
defend it to the death
sometimes conservatives can fail to
recognize that civil society had thrown
up institutions that we're good for one
ERA but not for another but generally
speaking the day after the Revolution
everyone is a conservative and the
American foundational ideals are radical
they're not stodgy in the English sense
conservatives in England live in the
monarchy in the Church of England they
believe in tradition they believe in the
House of Lords in America they don't now
there are certain fracture points at
which conservatives begin to side with
social institutions that libertarians
think are useless and my criticism of
libertarians the other direction is that
I think they can often fail to value
those social institutions they think the
world is that an algebra question give
some examples of that you know go back
to immigration you know the United
States is odd historically it's not how
most countries have been this this
relative peace these these classically
liberal ideas that the the inculcation
of due process and free speech and so
forth in the minds of the citizenry this
is these are are not normal
these are not normal no certainly not
common no and and they they didn't
spring up overnight
and I think that nations are more than
merely economies and that cult that what
keeps that going is partly the Bill of
Rights and partly the Supreme Court and
sort of the churches and the baseball
leagues but but it's partly people and a
long and slow train that runs back to
Britain and Magna Carta and time
immemorial and I think if you throw too
many new people in if you don't
recognize that there is some work to be
done with assimilation then your risk of
losing that well let me ask a final
question it's you know there's a there's
a fear among libertarians that
conservatives always come according
every presidential election season and
actually in 2003 National Review ran a
cover story talking about unpatriotic
dissenters in America and whatnot and
you know but that by to thought you know
as the election was heating up it was
like hey you know can't conservatives
and libertarians be friends you know
we're really on the same team here
libertarians are kind of doing well
lately if there's like gay marriage
things like pot legalization things like
criminal justice reform certain types of
disruptive innovations permissionless
innovation they're coming in in a
direction that seems to be going pretty
well for us
how do libertarians know that the idea
of being of a conservatory an outreach
is not just the old thing of like hey
you got a you got a role with us now
because we've got an election it's too
important to elect somebody who it does
not at least mouthed certain you know
certain oaths that libertarians like to
hear well I think that the conservatory
in term is not a linguistic trick it's a
substantive attempt to describe a
certain coterie on the right and the
good news is that the people that I'm
discussing by and large approve of all
of those developments that you're
discussing and this is an infusion
within the right in general you can call
it within conservatism within the
Republican Party or just within the
right if you like that is changing
conservatism and certainly
generationally is changed it's very
briefly than about the generational
aspect of this because it does seem I
mean we're used to were taught to talk
about things
in terms of right and left but it turns
out that it might be young and old or
whether chronologically are just kind of
mentally seems to be more well that's a
good point too because you know
progressives often like uber as well
I've I've never met and and I accept
there must be one out there I've never
met a young traditional conservative
whatever their views on gay marriage
who doesn't like uber over the taxi
Commission who doesn't prefer his iPhone
than the DMV or the IRS so I think
there's two things going on the first is
those libertarian ideals are being
applied to conservatives it's not as if
conservatives are playing nice the other
point is just generationally as you say
progressives liberals even socialists
are seduced by by this this market
change so in that area I don't think
you're going to have a problem you
probably will in foreign policy and
immigration I'll be honest with you yeah
no I I don't doubt that at all well
thank you it's a really interesting read
the conservatory at manifesto
libertarians conservatives and the fight
for the right future by Charles CW Cook
writer for National Review thanks so
much yeah I think you for having me I've
never met a conservative who calls
himself corporatist I've been a lot of
corporatists on Capitol Hill who call
themselves conservative